let's get more from washington and speak
to democratic representative jake
ochencloth very good evening to you um
certainly a real day of reflection there
in in washington but paint the scene for
us if you can about your personal
experience that day there you were just
three days into the job having just been
elected um what did you see here where
were you and how quickly did you realize
there was something wrong
good evening and thanks for having me on
as you say a somber day here in
washington as we commemorate the one
year anniversary of the insurrection it
was my third day in office a year ago
the day before i had been touring the
capitol with my father and reflecting on
the
gravity of the institution
and
the day
of the sixth when i first knew something
was seriously wrong was when the cordon
of capital police at the perimeter of
the building started to stagger
i was in the marine corps for a number
of years before coming to congress and
trained in crowd control tactics and i
know that when according begins to
stagger
it's going to break because people can
get in between the police officers and
get behind them and when i saw it
stagger i knew the crowd was going to
turn from ugly to violent
and that was really a heart-palpitating
moment unfortunately it went downhill
from there and i can recall standing on
the house floor that night
on broken glass surrounded by national
guardsmen and women with assault weapons
as we
voted to certify the election results
your previous guest the national
security adviser the former national
security adviser
is right that it was a heinous day he's
wrong that the system worked as it was
supposed to the system is not supposed
to work this way the bulwark of a
democracy is the peaceful transfer of
power
and
as joe biden said this morning
you can't only love your country when
you win
losers need to peacefully accede to the
winner and that was violated a year ago
it undercut the integrity of our
democracy and we are still in the midst
of this constitutional crisis this is
not a historical event this is a current
event
well why do you think donald trump did
not intervene for so long
i think a number of things one is as mr
bolton said he rarely has a plan 15
minutes in advance of anything he says
so i think he's just baseline
incompetent and
unable to
to plan or project forward and number
two complete megalomaniac and and
narcissist who liked the idea of people
rioting on his behalf
this is an individual who has never once
in his life put anything above his own
self-interest and we should not have
expected him to do so on january 6th and
we should certainly not expect him to do
so in the future
i mean lots of lessons need to be
learned just want to ask you one in in
in the context really of you being a
former marine lots of people there were
veterans now why would they feel it
necessary to idolize donald trump in
such a fashion to go and you know break
the rules of law by breaking into this
building
january 6th was the cresting of years of
diss and misinformation of polarization
born of
media that has come to profit off of an
outrage as a service model of elected
officials who have thrown red meat to
their base instead of trying to solve
solve problems with one another it was a
culmination of a lot of different
cancers within the body politic
and some of them we know how to excise
so
first and foremost
donald trump
this is a uniquely unfit individual for
the presidency and must never be allowed
to hold power again
but also shoring up the separation of
powers and the checks and balances that
our framers
uh left us and we have a bill in
congress to do that they're protecting
our democracy act we need to pass that
bill guaranteeing access to the ballot
box
pushing back on partisan gerrymandering
getting dark money out of politics we
got a bill to do those things too the
freedom to vote act we got to pass that
bill in congress so
as we as we commemorate this one-year
anniversary it must not be a day solely
of reflection but a day of action we
need to pass the laws that can prevent
this from occurring
when you say that or you say donald
trump should never be allowed to hold
power again that's that's not in your
gift is it i mean there's there's still
a real prospect for 2024 is there not
that he could be
the nominee for the republican party
well it would have been when we
impeached him
in the house after the insurrection had
he been convicted in the senate he would
have been precluded from holding office
and we still have the 14th amendment
section 3. that section states that if
you swear an oath of the constitution
and then incite insurrection against the
u.s government you're unfit to hold
office in the future we can we can uh
levy
that amendment against him to bar him
from holding office these are
these are going to be controversial
moves to take for sure and yet we've got
to account for the clear and present
danger to our constitutional republic
that he represents and continues to
represent
uh in terms of the the errors that were
made that night um why did it take four
hours to secure the capital
why when it was quite clear what was
happening in pictures broadcast for
several hours the predicted march on the
hill the stated aims of some of the
participants
why was it so poorly defended
i think there's no question that there
were both intelligence and tactical
failures
emanating from leadership of capital
police through
some of the uh federal and state
intelligence agencies to coordinate to
be candid though i find those to be the
less compelling points of investigation
than the broader systemic issues of how
we got to an insurrectionist mob outside
of the capitol in the first place part
of the reason that january 6 was allowed
to happen as you state is that it was
unimaginable in america ahead of that
date that this could ever happen
and
what went from unimaginable to
inexorable needs to be the the true
cause for investigation how did we get
here as a democracy
and and yet there are still large
numbers of people in america who think
joe biden didn't win it's a form of
dysfunctional democracy and what message
does that send to the world really as
the us wants to hold autocrats to
account that you can't persuade your own
people that you held a lawful election
70 of republican voters to a certain
extent believe that
the election was stolen from donald
trump and as you say it is harder for us
to be a beacon of democracy and for us
to exert more leadership on the world
stage especially in an era when we're
competing against the chinese communist
party which ideologically is not
committed to free and fair elections uh
when we ourselves
cannot guarantee the peaceful transfer
of power through those free and fair
elections so
as we defend democracy abroad that work
begins at home
and just just very quickly
i was on that night the pictures
available subsequently from inside and
from those pressure points you talked
about you know the windows being broken
into the doors the the corridors where
there was literally a battle was there
not with law enforcement officials and
and the protesters many of your
colleagues have said they really thought
they were going to die that night is is
did did that cross your mind is that is
that the mood in the building
i was barricaded in my office i never
feel feared for my own physical safety
but then again
people weren't calling my name hunting
me down the hallways as they were for
some of my colleagues
well jake open class um good to have
your thoughts thank you very much indeed
there are u.s congress representatives
from massachusetts